[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a un petit côté drôle mais encore
une fois on se moque des religions
et Rabbi Jacob n'est pas la même
aujourd'hui c'est du mec qu'on se moque
c'est pas de la fille la fille c'est
juste le elle sert le gars
ça pourrait être un prêtre pas du tout
ah bah non arrête de prendre la parole
et bien sûr parce que c'est le prétexte
pour se moquer des religions
je suis désolé une bonne sœur on se
moque d'elle ça fait rire le silence à
la fin pour moi je vais vous dire c'est
presque blasphématoire
[Applaudissements]
direct non là on voit juste c'est pas
une vraie bonne sœur
[Rires]
merde 1000 fois évidemment c'est Patrick
maintenant oui oui
alors
il faut toujours qu'ils disent aïe à la
place des autres c'est ouf est-ce qu'il
y a une association catholique est-ce
qu'elle est prêtre qui sont révoltés
est-ce qu'il y a des associations de non
qui ont dit que c'était choquant non toi
faut toujours que tu es mal à la place
des autres
à ta place je dis j'ai mal j'ai le droit
de dire j'ai mal
j'ai mal
sous les mains Gilles Patrick
ça vous plaît l'émission beaucoup je
suis très content
moi je suis d'accord en vrai je suis
d'accord avec Patrick donc quand on
touche à la religion c'est un peu
compliqué et là je trouve que en vrai ce
qui est drôle c'est la réaction du mec à
la fin il va finir quand on réfléchit
elle veut dire quoi cette cette caméra
cachée elle veut dire que quoi que quand
on est une une bonne sœur on peut pas
être belle que les bonnes heures
de faire rire avec une caméra cachée que
la religion il y a des gens que ça peut
blesser donc à partir de ce moment-là il
faut pas le faire et imaginez-le qu'on
aurait fait que d'autres religions
serait aussi choper et là je pense que
ça choque les catholiques ou en tout cas
certains et je comprends ce que dit non
mais si tu arrêtes de bouger parce que
ça peut choquer quelqu'un tu fais plus
jamais rien le fait de rire à une blague
juive si tu devenais encore
sur la réaction du mec mais le le
caractère religieux de la blague ne fait
pas rire en fait on sait très bien que
c'est une fausse bonne sœur donc c'est
pas une insulte on sait très bien que
c'est une fausse
tu disais c'est une insulte aux aveugles
mais non tout le monde savait que
c'était une blague
de la religion et de toutes les
religions et il faut c'est un flammable
aujourd'hui la religion
que Gilles Verdez et donc toi Guillaume
j'entends en fait
non je pense que vous êtes des dangers
publics en fait je pense que vous créez
du racisme vous créez vous créez de la
stigmatisation en tenant des propos
comme ça parce que avant on rigolait
tout ça il y avait pas beaucoup plus de
racisme c'est aujourd'hui que les les
gens sont extrêmement divisés c'est
aujourd'hui qu'on crée des communautés
qui se regardent comme ça qui se jauge
où personne n'a le droit de rigoler avec
personne et donc c'est juste
insupportable et je pense que vous le
danger tu peux faire la même vanne sans
que ce soit pas drôle mais si tu veux
quoi
on aurait fait ça avec une femme voil ée
c'est ce qui fait ça qu'une femme voilée
bah oui pourquoi pas oui
un pays comme le nôtre on a le droit de
rigoler des religions à d'autres pays où
on a pas le droit et quand on se moque
des religions on va en prison on risque
la peine de voir une satire excuse-moi
c'est gratte non je sais pas une satire
c'est gratuit et moi je suis plutôt
comme Patrick et ma couille à côté
non mais c'est vrai ça moi ça me choque
et c'est facile de le faire sur la
religion catholique ça ça mange pas de
quoi ça fait rire tout le monde du
chocolat dans la gueule c'était pas de
la soute aux pâtissier on galop dans le
chocolat
il faut se moquer de tout le monde et de
tous parce que ça veut dire qu'on est
tous inclus et tous on est tous ensemble
on fait pas des clans comme ça moi je
pense pas
qu'il faut pas mélanger le contexte en
fait le contexte c'est pas dans une
église elle fait ça dans une église il
fait cette caméra cachée dans une équipe
je suis pas content et je suis le
premier à dire de pas me toucher aux
religion mais là c'est à la place c'est
un mec qui se fait qui se fait piéger
par une nana c'est rigolo ça veut dire
en train de dire que les bonnes sœurs
alors elles sont jamais elles ont pas
mal
j'ai envie d'interdire ce genre de
choses je suis choqué est-ce qu'on a
encore le droit de choquer de conduire
parce que c'est grave et je ne vois pas
pourquoi
on s'en moque comme ça gratuitement
on s'amuse et ça fait rire tout le monde
est-ce qu'on peut être voilà est-ce
qu'on peut jouer première à rire de ça
sûrement non en fait on sait que j'ai
parlé une seconde déjà parlé oui
je suis persuadé que les religieuses si
elles voient ça elles vont s'amuser
aussi elles vont rire
vous pouvez peut-être me renseigner vous
connaissez ce monsieur
comique c'est pas du tout que ce soit
une bonne sœur c'est juste qu'il pensait
que c'était une femme peut-être âgée et
qui découvre qu'elle est très jolie
contre
on se moque de la dignité
est-ce qu'elle peut venir pour tes
moyens
de savoir ce qu'elle en pense donc pas
de la dignité
juste voir comment elle a vécu le truc
ça se trouve elle est traumatisée cet
enfant
ah oui ah oui
au contraire ça me donnait envie aux
gens de se rapprocher de la religion en
général les choses
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]